courtney is in norfolk virginia hi
courtney welcome to the dave ramsey shop
hey can you guys hear me okay
yeah what's going on uh so oh my god i'm
already about to
cry um i've been staying at home with
the baby for the last like six months
and money's just really tight so i don't
know
if i can keep doing it or if i should go
to work
or what to do really
okay let's let's dig into it let's let's
unpack this what
when you say money is tight kind of tell
us a little bit about your financial
situation and are you
home because you want to be home or what
what's going on kind of walk us through
your decisions of what's going on
uh so i quit working when i was about
six months pregnant because i was so
sick i couldn't drive my husband's
military
so he brings home about 3 400 a month
but
without our mortgage we're like 23 000
in debt
okay so it's kind of hard to stay on top
of things and be able to save and do
things we want to do without having
to stress about it yeah what are things
you want to do what do you mean
anything because right now he
my husband gets pretty mad uh because
when he wants to go do things i'm like
no i want to use that money
instead of going out to eat on a date i
want to pay it on a credit card
i i don't want debt i'm sick of it but
he's the kind of person who's like oh
another 50 bucks on the card won't hurt
yeah but i can't do that how what's the
uh
23 000 in debt is that all credit cards
uh
no so 15 000 of it is his card that i've
tried
many times to get him to sell it
but they he thinks her name is a cuss
word so
he does not want to get rid of his car
whatsoever but the rest of that
is credit cards
okay you don't have a money problem you
have a husband problem
yeah this isn't even a question of being
a stay-at-home mom or working
that's not that's actually not the root
of what's going on just like dave said
yeah i think i think you guys are
destined to spend
some time with a marriage counselor
because it hasn't gotten to do with my
name being a cuss word
it's it's got to do with you have a set
of goals and he wants to just spend
money
and you guys cannot pay the bills
and so in other words he wants to keep a
car
that you guys cannot afford and that is
forcing you
into the workplace so you're trading a
car
his his desire for that car over your
desire to be at home
that's the conflict mathematically
mathematically if you're in the car
payments you could pull it off
well and if you if you do go get a job
or start your own business or create any
kind of income that is taking you away
from your
baby which is where you want to be it's
still not going to fix the root problem
which is you and your husband are not on
the same page
you're going to make more money to pay
for those things that you want to do but
you're going to resent him by the fact
that you have to
and you don't get to be with your baby
because you're not on the same page
right
yeah so uh what you guys have got to do
is is it's not a dave ramsey or christy
right answer really
and it's not a is can i afford to stay
at home the answer is you already told
me you can't afford to stay at home
because you have a car you can't afford
and so
i think the math is pretty simple you
guys get on a written plan together both
of your grown-ups raising a child and
um get rid of the car and i think you'll
be able to stay at home
mathematically uh if that's your desire
and it sounds like that's your desire
so um and but it's you know
in other words the your desire for this
and the cha
and you being there with the child has
got to come before his desire for a
truck
and that's called being a grown-up
so yeah how old are you guys 20.
yeah all right well i i
you know this is his challenge to move
from being a little boy that wants
everything to being a man that serves
his family
and um every one of us has to do that i
i
had the exact same thing at my house
many years ago
i'm an old guy now but uh many years ago
i had to make the decision that it was
not all about dave
and um that i've got three kids to raise
and feed and uh
and you know a wife that has a vote
and so you you guys need to sit down
with a good marriage counselor as soon
as possible
and spend some time and if he won't go
you go without him
uh and go go see account because that'll
start to give you some language
to pull this together because this is
not gonna get better it's gonna get
worse
and it's just showing up now
that the choices he's making are you
know
meaning you don't have a vote and he's
putting his selfish desires ahead of
your
family yeah it's interesting too because
so often what we think
is a money issue is really a values
issue
what you're talking about are your
values your dreams your goals that's
that's actually money is just what
you're
putting towards them in his case he
values the car
in your case you're valuing being at
home and so you've got to get to the
root level and talk about the values
that's what we're really talking about
here the money's just like you said
where the where the symptom where the
evidence is coming out of what
what the problem is i can't tell you the
number of times in 30 years of doing
financial coaching that we can sell a
car and enables mom to stay home that
wants to stay home
didn't she say he's deployed too do you
need a car if he's deployed
i think she said he's deployed oh well
that's going to make marriage counseling
a little difficult
but um uh we'll have to wait he gets
back i guess
but like you said she can go and put
some language for the conversations
around it
yeah yeah that won't hurt but you don't
need a car
bottom line is this is not a car you
don't trade a kid for a car
you don't trade time at home if mom
wants to be at home you don't trade that
for a car
and sometimes you have to say it like
that to really see what you're talking
about like that's what you're really
good at dave is just like
calling it like it is and calling it out
and when you see it like they're like oh
like all the
all the the ways that we danced around
this issue and walked on eggshells i was
like no that's really what we're doing
and neither of us are okay with that
hopefully he's not okay with that so
we're going to do something about it
yeah
well and it's a different answer if she
wants to be in the workplace
a hundred she's a professional lady and
rushed to do something that's what i
love helping women do
or start businesses from home whatever
the thing is i would love to help her do
that but you hear in her voice she
doesn't want to
yeah that's what she wants to do she
started the call with tears yeah that's
right and so
uh you know but but yeah so change the
equation then
if we want to choose to move ahead
financially and
pay off the car and keep it um because
we like the car
and i'm working i'm working and i
realize i'm working for that then you
don't say you're trading a kid for a car
because i'm not going to shame i'm going
to mom shame her right oh 100
that's the thing so it's not that it's a
different but it's got to do with
you know your money flows toward what
you care about your values that's right
when you care about saving money flows
towards saving when you care about
giving
and being generous it flows towards
generosity money flows towards
what you care about just let you spend
your time and your money
on what matters to you and you know
it's just it's infallible to look at it
that way